حاولات الحد من الانتشار المتسارع
للمخدرات في العراق مستمره مجلس النوادي
يدرس مقترحا جديدا لتعديل قانون مكافحه
المخدرات يتضمن فرض فحص دوريا لشرائح
واسعه من المجتمع العراقي كما طالب عدد من
اعضاء المجلس فحص كافه الموظفين في القطاع
العام والخاص والدرجات الوظيفيه العامه
والخاصه والطلبه في المدارس المتوسطه
والاعداديه والجامعات الحكوميه والاهليه
والمتقدمين للتعيين مديريه مكافحه
المخدرات في وزاره الداخليه العراقيه رحبت
في المقترح الجديد شريطه ان يكون مدروسا
ليحقق نتائجها المرجوه ندعم كل المقترحات
في محاربه
المخدرات اللي بدات تشرب وسط مجتمعنا وسط
شبابنا ولكن هذه التعديلات تحتاج الى الى
دراسه من قبل الهيئه الوطنيه العليا
المكافحه المخدرات العشائر العراقيه دخلت
على الخط المقترح الجديد سيكون مدعوما
بجهود شيوخ العشائر باتجاه تسهيل مهمه
انجاح تنفيذ المقترح من خلال جمله من
النقاط طبعا هو بجانب الاول هو التوعيه
والارشاد ومتابعه ال ال العناصر التي تروج
على هذه الظاهره الخطيره من خلال الاتجار
بها او التعاطي المقترح الجديد ويتناغمه
مع رغبه المشرع العراقي في تجديد
الاجراءات القانونيه الخاصه بمكافحه
المخدرات على امل نجاح الاجراءات
التنفيذيه في الحد من انتشار الانتشار
بالمخدرات وتعاطيها